I will actually turn though to the
conservative leadership contest and
Rishi sunak is now the clear
front-runner after Boris Johnson quit
the race last night it leaves Penny
mordant as the only other candidate to
publicly stand against the former
Chancellor joining us now on the program
the Home Secretary and of course the
supporter of Richie sunac Grand chaps Mr
Sharps very good morning to you um
you're practically a brand ambassador
for Excel these days so do tell me what
did the spreadsheet say about the
veracity of Boris Johnson's claim to
have 102 102 nominations
well it won't surprise you to learn that
since I became um Home Secretary last
week actually my head has been buried in
counter-terrorism briefings uh security
briefings and other things so I have not
actually been able to perform uh that
role I've been looking after the the
Safety and Security of the country
instead
um but uh you know I saw Boris Johnson's
um statement last night he said he had
uh the numbers but in the interest of
both party unity and the country uh he
said he would withdraw and I have to say
I think he did the right thing I think
that is that sensible under the
circumstances I think Boris Johnson was
uh you know actually in many ways
a very impressive uh prime minister what
with his response to getting beyond the
brexit thing the covered vaccine roll
out his response so why not know that I
think he did a lot of good things
for him to be able to I was going to say
I think you're probably a bit too early
for him to make a return there's still
that parliamentary investigation uh
outstanding and I think he recognized
that actually within the Parliamentary
party so in other words within
conservative MPS uh probably it was just
too soon to be returning to the fold
without some of these other matters
resolves and so I think that's why he
decided not to go again but I I think
actually you know as a party we think
that there are a lot of very very good
things he did but he's recognized that
through the unity of the the country and
now is not the time and I think that's
why he withdrew
should we take it from what you've said
then that you're now calling on Penny
Morton to do the same and step aside
no is it I know it's up to her but what
do you think should she do it or not
yeah well I was going to I was going to
say what I do know is that Rishi enjoys
the support of a large number of uh
conservative MPS and there's a very high
nomination threshold of a hundred so
um you know
putting it the other way around really
she doesn't think that it's in the bag
he's speaking to colleagues this morning
he's working very hard to attract those
supporters who were perhaps with Boris
Johnson uh previously but you know look
I'll leave it to Penny she's a terrific
colleague let's see what happens but we
won't have to wait very long because by
this lunch time I think specifically two
o'clock we will know the answer to all
of this and we'll see whether it does
indeed go to a second round which means
out to the membership in the country or
whether indeed it's all over at that
stage but nothing taken taken for
granted by Rishi at this stage
I mean you and of course you were
transport secretary under Boris Johnson
you then supported Rishi sunat during
his well the previous failed bid to
become the leader uh you're now home
secretary under uh Liz truss uh I mean
the only person you haven't supported is
Penny Morden I mean aren't we just in a
kind of a position at the moment right
now where we have to take you at your
word that you believe that Rishi sunak
is the best candidate despite the fact
you've worked for no plenty of other
people as well
well I'm very grateful to uh the the uh
to Liz trust for uh appointed Me Home
Secretary of course is incredibly
important job looking after you know the
security of the of the nation in so many
different ways uh as you already pointed
out I didn't actually support Liz truss
I did support Rishi Summit I mean to be
honest becoming homesick actually in her
government does strike me as a fairly
much a statement of support
well look I just actually I mean call me
old-fashioned but I just think it's a
matter of public service and and Duty uh
we're living in incredibly uh dangerous
times uh we've got this war in Ukraine
and all the spin-off from that Homeland
Security and what's happening in this
country uh enormously important I'm here
in my constituency in Welling Garden
right now and you know I know that what
people want is safety on the streets
security at home and I think that the
job of of Home Secretary is a very very
important role to fulfill so you know I
I there's no politics involved in making
sure that we're doing a good job on the
most basic things that a government must
do which is look after its people and
its borders and that's why I was uh
pleased to accept the position of of
Home Secretary but as you rightly point
out I supported Rishi sunac in the
summer because I thought that
economically he understood what this
country uh needed and obviously improve
right uh look what's happened since
well just just on that point how much do
you know of the strategy the economic
strategy that Rishi sunlight will be
coming forward I mean for example
National Insurance should we expect to
see it going back up again
no that's been voted through uh and uh
Rishi said he would leave that as things
are now and actually he set out a very
detailed program uh through all of those
weeks of the leadership contest in the
summer so unfortunately we know a lot
about what he'd do of course the main
thing is we know how he performed as
Chancellor through the coronavirus
pandemic as well so you know actually we
can be pretty sure about the way he'll
behave it's very straightforward he'll
he'll Bear Down on inflation he'll get
growth in the economy and he'll reduce
taxes but it'll do it in that order
which I think is really important
because that's what gives security and
confidence to the markets and therefore
to the population
sure but it isn't no potentially the
time for this to all be put to the
public once again you know four Prime
Ministers and not very long to suggest
that perhaps there isn't the Mandate
there for Rishi sunak that there was
previously I mean the last uh totally
leadership election was decided by party
members representing about 0.3 of the
electorate this time the leadership's
being decided by you and your colleagues
who represent I might just work this out
not Point not not not not seven percent
of the electorate 700 000 of one percent
surely it is no time to let the British
public have a bit of a seat in who
actually runs this country
well so I'm standing here in my
constituency uh well in Hatfield I'm in
well in Garden City and every single
person uh had the opportunity here to
vote I'm very grateful they elected me
last time around in 2019. I haven't
changed and I'm still here and the same
is the case in 650 constituencies around
the country we elect a party and we
elect uh individuals as members of that
party and the 2019 Manifesto is actually
the thing the document if you like that
Rishi is standing on so none we don't
tend to have four prime ministers in
three years though
uh of course it's unusual I I I give you
that but one of those Prime Ministers is
one who's elected with that Manifesto of
course uh so you're slightly playing
figures there but but nonetheless the
individuals who were elected and I was
on the ballot paper are still the same
individuals who are in place and there's
a five-year program and we will be
delivering that Manifesto now you're
absolutely right the beans and bumps not
just change in prime ministers but uh
also covid also the war in Ukraine along
the way so it has been a very very uh
difficult period but the manifesto is
the manifesto and that is primarily if
you want to see what Rishi is going to
be doing it's all there
I mean all of that would make sense if
the previous prime minister hadn't was
in fact the current prime minister I
should say it hadn't torn up the 2019
Manifesto and danced on its grave I mean
the point I'm trying to make is we have
been through so many iterations of the
conservative party recently that whilst
you're absolutely right there was
nothing constitutionally wrong with what
is happening at the moment you might
suggest that the public should have a
bit of a say in this I mean think of it
this way isn't it simply the case that
because you know Rishi sunak you know
isn't even popular with the conservative
party membership in a leadership contest
he can't get the conservatives to vote
for him in a leadership contest What
chan says they're of them voting Forum
in a general election isn't that what's
at stake here the Electoral Oblivion
that the conservative party faces if you
are bold enough to call a general
election
also I mean actually I I think the way
you describes it quite quite it's quite
interesting because there wasn't a sense
an Excursion a diversion uh from the
2019 Manifesto in some ways particularly
in in terms of uh tax policy and
fiscally
um over the uh the last couple of months
uh which will be now returning to you
know what we said we should do all along
which is make sure that we run a
responsible economy that the you know
for example as things stand at the
moment inflation is born down on we get
economic growth and then we can reduce
taxes but you've got to do it in that
order and so actually in a way this is
more authentic to the 2019 Manifesto and
anyway either way after five years
people get to judge
um the the the the the the outcome of
the votes that they place I don't
disagree that
um you know there is a lot to do and a
lot to prove we've had all the
distractions of coronavirus we've got
the war in Ukraine causing that
inflation but in two years time voters
around here in well in Hatfield around
the country they'll be able to make
their decisions known and they'll be
able to do it based on the 2019
Manifesto did we deliver it did we are
they content with that and they'll be
able to make their minds up so so look I
I I think we can we can wait to see uh
in the meantime I'm very hopeful that
Rishi will be successful but we'll have
to wait and see at least until this
lunch time and maybe longer to find out
um Minister just a final couple of
questions genuinely what has been the
point of the conservative party for the
last three months
well look I I did I didn't vote for what
we've had over the the last uh couple of
months I think it is since your
colleagues did that's the point this has
been in power because I was well mostly
MPS didn't it was it you as you rightly
pointed out
um that the view was taken in the
country amongst the membership
membership uh to go in a certain
direction I think it's fair to say that
it hasn't worked and the current prime
minister has acknowledged that and of
course resigned as a result I think this
is the opportunity to make sure that we
are the parties that stumble
conservatives have always done looked
after you know the the pound in your
pocket looked after the the country
financially uh because we come back to
the same question you've just conceded
you've just conceded that it didn't work
that Liz trust didn't work you know the
conservative party pooped her and it
should be trust the conservative party
again
exactly yeah and she can she she said
the same thing herself but but look what
I would say is actually uh interestingly
and it happened during uh Liz's time in
Downing Street we hit the lowest
unemployment that this country has seen
since
1973 and conservatives as ever are the
of the party of high employment low
unemployment and that's something that's
very good that's happened so I think you
know it's not it's not the case that
that everything has been uh everything
has been bad level's important are
incredibly important but I think as Liz
truss accepted herself that the
experiment with reducing taxes and doing
that on borrowing does not work and it's
it's a good reason to put that right
very quickly as I say I think Rishi has
the right plan for that is proven as a
Chancellor and he was right about
everything that he said in the summer
about what would happen if you tried to
go down that route which is why I think
it's uh he's the right person to to lead
this country
Grant chaps always good to talk to you
thanks for joining us this morning on
breakfast